our scripture today Hebrews 12:11 no
discipline seems Pleasant at the time
but painful later on however it produces
a harvest of righteousness and peace for
those who have been trained by it Henry
Ward Beecher says the little troubles
and worries of life may be as stumbling
blocks in our way or we may make them
stepping stones to a nobler character
and heaven troubles are often the tools
by which God fashions us for better
things a Henry Ward Beecher were you to
have said that in this day and time and
dared to put that on a blog you would be
accused of hating the poor the little
troubles and worries of life maybe as
stumbling blocks in our way we may make
them stepping stones to a nobler
character into heaven troubles are often
the tools by which god fashions us for
better things see Henry you're just a
hater that's what you are you're just a
hater Henry who knew Henry Ward Beecher
was a hater can you note the sarcasm I
just want to make sure you catch the
circuit no discipline seems Pleasant at
the time but painful later on however it
produces a harvest of righteousness and
peace for those who have been trained by
it if you live like no one else later
you can live and give like no one else
it's across the bottom of every page on
almost 5 million Total Money Makeover
books it comes from that scripture if
you live like no one else later you can
live and give like no one else you have
to pay a price to win if you win without
price I don't think you won and you
really don't end up with anything right
it's it's very rare and Dave all those
rich people they they inherited their
money I hear that all the time you know
the interesting thing is is the research
the facts don't back up that mythology
they know Tom Stanley did a ton of
research in The Millionaire Next Door
and he discovered that 88 percent or
about 9 out of 10 millionaires in
America today our first generation rich
9 out of 10 or first generation rich
started with nothing got up left the
cave killed something and drug it on
they changed their life they broke free
from the chains of their heritage their
community their education the things
that would hold them back the hurdles
that they had to climb over and their
every color and their every sex and
their every nationality there's no rhyme
or reason to it just some people go do
it oh by the way the Forbes 400 which is
the 400 wealthiest people in North
America today as rated by Forbes
magazine of the 400 a little over 300 of
them are billionaires that's a thousand
a million of those 67 percent two-thirds
of them approximately you know
approximately 250 260 of them out of the
400 are first-generation rich and that's
billionaires and in many cases multi
billionaires see Warren Buffett's
first-generation rich the Walton family
are Sam Walton was first-generation rich
the molten kids today our second
generation rich but first generation
rich
interesting to think about in other
words the troubles that you have and the
worries of life can be stumbling blocks
in our way or we can make them stepping
stones you see I've discovered that the
gleaming mountain of success is not
really a gleaming mountain it's more
like a pile of garbage but you're just
standing on it versus laying under the
garbage most of us that have achieved
any level of scale to success in parts
of our lives or whether it's wealth or
marriage or kids or our spiritual walk
or whatever have had a massive number of
failures along the way and for some
reason just didn't quit and you can list
company after company person after
person oh here's a really weird one for
you insurance company did this for piece
of research that shows that if you
immigrate to this country if you come to
this country from another country
legally I need to enunciate that
carefully you come here legally under a
visa and proper immigration laws and so
forth you are four times more likely to
end up a millionaire then one of us good
old boys who was homegrown here the
reason is is that people believe in this
country sometimes people who don't live
here believe in this country more than
those of us who live here I mean why is
it that people for instance in the
Vietnamese communities have unbelievable
success ratios why is that now certainly
there's some turkeys that are Vietnamese
don't misunderstand just like there's
rednecks and hillbillies like me that
are good people and there's some turkeys
in that group as well we can so we can
say this about any group why is that why
is it that you can take I think you can
know the story yeah I read one of them
in Chicken Soup for the Soul
remember that old book Chicken Soup for
the Soul was about a family that came
from an Asian country and they
I opened the dry cleaner and they lived
in the back of the dry cleaners and and
they Litton then they lived upstairs
above the dry cleaners or the middle of
money they built it out and then they
bought another dry cleaners and they
bought another dry cleaners and they
bought another dry cleaners and they
behind other dry cleaners and they're
still living upstairs and the dry
cleaners because they were more
concerned about changing the future of
the next generation and they were their
current comfort but too many people now
sacrifice their future for their current
comfort one definition of maturity is
learning to delay pleasure immature
people can't delete can't delay pleasure
adults devise a plan and follow it
children do what feels good and so live
like no one else so that later you can
live and give like no one else and not
only so you can do that but so that you
completely change your family tree you
live and leave a legacy no discipline
seems Pleasant at the time but painful
later on however it produces a harvest
of righteousness and peace for those who
have been trained by it live like no one
else so that later you can live and give
like no one else if those actions didn't
have positive results why would anyone
do them I got to tell you I love
desserts this time of year so on me
I'm just got a sweet tooth from now on
red meat and desserts
these are Dave things right here you
know I just i man a big old steak and a
huge slice of homemade pecan pie
afterwards I just can't think of my
mouth is watering right now beyond
belief I love desserts there's a direct
correlation between the size of my belly
and the amount of desserts I eat there's
a direct correlation between my physical
condition and how much time I spend
running or or on the elliptical or
lifting or doing whatever I'm going to
do to get aerobic activity to burn off
some of that kanpai
man I got to stay away from that stuff
I have to pay a price to win otherwise I
get so big I can't waddle because I just
like sweet you guys but I can't just sit
here and be fat and go it's McDonald's
fault there's a systemic breakdown the
caloric intake of the average American
has got me down I mean the way people
view food in this culture I'm just stuck
there's nothing I can do I'm a victim I
can't do that be as big as a freaking
house if I do that I have to understand
that my actions have consequences you
know what that's called common sense a
lot of people don't have common sense
anymore that's why this show is so
popular